you talk about sexual discipline for a
man for a man in particular I had seen a
clip uh I think oh it's your Instagram
Tyler can you can you flip to me to
number six and play his IG and then we
can get your reactions it's your words
but I want the audience to hear it
but most men lack all sexual discipline
their bodies say PornHub
they do
their body says she's here they they
have no discipline there's going to come
a time in the day
for all the guys who struggle with
pornography that that woman that you've
seen that pornography video is gonna
want you in person and you're going to
be married and you're going to have
children
and if you've never learned
I'm not talking about the average Betty
I'm not talking about no you know big
beluga whales I'm talking about the
woman that these you're watching on
those videos a woman like that is gonna
want you in 3D and she's gonna and the
difference is it's one thing when you're
having to talk to her and no she's she's
on you she's she's right on it yeah and
if you never learn discipline I'm
telling you literally you will fall and
you can so that's a unique message that
I don't hear a lot um from the red pill
community in particular and oftentimes
some some of them will say well a guy
doesn't need to exercise any discipline
at all because there's a separate set of
rules for men and women I'm somebody who
believes create the relationship you
want create the Paradigm you want if it
makes you happy I don't care as long as
you're both in it you understand the
terms and no one's cheating or doing
anything nasty but this idea of sexual
discipline is interesting to me why is
it important for men and how do they how
do they get that how do they exercise
that muscle great question I think the
uniqueness between me is I come from a a
faith-based background that's that's the
foundation of my ideas I truly believe
in order to speak the truth you must go
to the source of the truth which I
believe is God and so to me I'm obsessed
I don't care about me being right I care
about the truth going out so I love
learning from different people I love
learning and improving because I'm
obsessed with the truth going out a lot
of these people especially in the repo
Community they swear that they have the
truth men beware any individual in this
planet who says I am the way I am the
truth you listen to me I will tell you
everything right about life that's a
cult leader one-on-one versus somebody
who says yo I'm trying to Aspire for the
truth I want you to investigate learn
for yourself and I want you to find
what's best for you in your life so all
these individuals in those communities
who sweated that the orders of truth
they're extremely dis dishonest and
extremely destructive to the lives of
innocent young men who do not know and I
want the men to use their wisdom to
figure out the truth for themselves so
going back to sexual discipline because
of having a Facebook faith-based
background in Christian theology you
learn about the importance of sexual
discipline especially when you
understand the story of Samson
story of Samson in the Bible is a deep
story I hate how people treat Bible
story stories like the children story
they're not children's stories it's a
really deep story so long story short
Samson is a Israelite judge and back in
the day a judge wasn't like a judge and
gavel those were actually leaders so he
was one of the leaders of the Israelite
Israelite people there was a rule and
back in those days in Israel where you
do not marry non-jewish women so like
there's like the land was called a
Canaanites you don't marry Canaanite
women Samson did not follow that rule he
loved the Canaanite women and the story
continues to continue so one day he's
with a woman named Delilah and and
Delilah was actually paid off by
Samson's enemies to want to kill him but
Samson was a super strong guy he had all
the muscles all the strength and no one
can kill Sam's because he's super
powerful but they needed to find
Samson's weakness so they used Delilah
to find out Samson's weakness because
after in bed during pillow talk after he
did his thing she would ask Samson
what's your weakness Samson what's weak
where's your weakness and eventually
told her his weakness which is his hair
this is when she cut his hair the guys
came in and they they took Samson away
that story and so many more teach you
about as a man if you do not have
discipline over your body you have
discipline over your decision making
those decisions will ruin your life so
to me I've clearly seen that as a man
that if you have the wrong woman in your
life if you bring the wrong person into
your life it will ruin your life so to
me I've seen so many stories
of men who they are married to the wrong
women why because they were so obsessed
with having sex they never actually
vetted her never asked the right
question and never see if she's a woman
of character all they were consumed with
was what she did in the bedroom but if
that man had sexual discipline and sex
wasn't the end all be all of his life
guess what could happen he could
actually objectively analyze her to see
if she actually fit his life and to
avoid the train wreck before it occurred
on top of that with pornography how many
men today struggle with pornography
they're spending hours upon hours of
days watching pornography they came in
Focus did I I hear a story of a man
after man dealing with it why because
they never had sexual discipline and to
my last point
as a man if your whole life you went
from I see I smash I see I smash I see I
smash one day you get married
or one day let's say you're
anti-marriage guy like those red pill
extremists let's say when you're in a
relationship with a woman that you
actually value
and maybe one day you you're like you
know what I'm done sleeping around you
you talk to her about yo it's just you
and me and then all of a sudden because
you never lack you never learned
discipline you then sleep around for
another woman you get her pregnant
what happens to your relationship I
cannot tell you how many men today ruin
a great woman because they lack sexual
discipline and so to me there's 75 other
ways that sexual sexual discipline
benefits a man's life but so many men
today the reason that they struggle is
because of discipline and it also so
many men they're not even about their
purpose they're about getting laid the
only reason some people are making money
only some people are in the gym because
they're trying to get laid but imagine
if you weren't so consumed with sex and
you're actually consumer becoming a
better human being imagine how many
great things you can accomplish imagine
how great of a person you can be and so
my biggest thing is that when you are a
guy and you're constantly flooding your
brain where pornographic images when you
constantly flooding your brain with
simply trying to go out and sleep around
there is no way that you can be on your
purpose and fulfill the the purpose that
God has put on this planet for you to
achieve and so sexual discipline to me
is a man's superpower and so little men
have that ability in their lives if you
want to watch the full episode click
right here and if you want to ask me a
question talk one-on-one send me a
FaceTime video join a video with a group
of your friends and me you gotta
download manect and you gotta join me
there it's gonna be really hot
[Music]